The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So we are going
to switch directions.
Rather than thinking
about binary variables,
these Ising variables,
that were discrete,
think again about a lattice.
But now at each site we put a
spin that has unit magnitude,
but m component.
That is, Si has
components 1, 2, to n.
And the constraint that this
sum over alpha Si alpha squared
is unit.
So clearly, if I-- let's
put it here explicitly.
Alpha of 1 to n, so that's
when I look at the case of n
equals to 1, essentially
I have one component.
2 squared has to be 1, so
it's either plus or minus.
We recover the Ising variable.
For n equals to 2,
it's essentially
a unit vector who's
angle theta, for example,
can change in three dimensions
if we were exploring
the surface of the cube.
And we always
assume that we have
a weight that tends to make
our spins to be parallel.
So we use, essentially, the
same form as the Ising model.
We sum over near neighbors.
And the interaction,
rather than sigma I sigma
j, we put it as this
Si dot Sj, where
these are the dot
products of two vectors.
Let's call the dimensionless
interaction in front K0.
So when we want to calculate
the partition function,
we need to integrate
over all configurations
of these spins of this weight.
Now for each case, we
have to do n components.
But there is a constraint,
which is this one.
Now I'm going to be focused
on the ground state.
So when t equals to 0, we
expect that spontaneously
the particular configuration
will be chosen.
Everybody will be aligned
to that configuration.
Without loss of generality,
let's choose aligned state
to point along the
last component.
That is, all of the
Si at t equal to 0
will be of the form 0,0, except
that the last component is
pointing along some
particular direction.
So if it was two components, the
y component would always be 1.
It would be aligned
along the y direction.
Yes, question?
AUDIENCE: What dimensionality
is the lattice?
PROFESSOR: It can be anything.
So basically we have two
parameters, as usual.
n is the dimensionality
of spin, and d
would be the dimensionality
of our lattice.
In practice for what
the calculations
that we are going
to be doing, we
will be focusing in
d that is close to 2.
Now if the odd fluctuations
at finite t, what happens
is that the state of the
vector is going to change.
So this Si at finite
temperature would no longer
be pointing along
the last component.
It will start to
have fluctuations.
Those fluctuations will change
the 0 from the ground state
to some value I'll call
pi 1, the next one pi 2,
all of the big pi n minus 1.
And since the whole entire
thing is a unit vector,
the last component has to
shrink to adjust for that.
So we would indicate the
last component by sigma.
So essentially this subspace of
fluctuations around the ground
state is captured
through this vector
pi that is n minus
1 dimensional.
And this corresponds
to the transverse modes
that we're looking
at when we were doing
the expansion of the
Landau-Ginzburg model
around its symmetry
broken state.
In this case, the
longitudinal mode,
essentially, is
infinitely stiff.
You don't have the
ability to stretch along
the longitudinal mode
because of the constraint
that we have put over here.
So if you think back,
we had this wine bottle,
or Mexican hat potential.
And the Goldstone
modes corresponded
to going along the
bottom, and how easy
it was to climb
this Mexican hat was
determined by the
longitudinal mode.
In this case, the Mexican hat
has become very, very stiff
to climb on the sides.
So you don't have the
longitudinal mode.
You just have these
Goldstone modes.
The cost to pay
for that is that I
have to be very careful in
calculating the partition
function.
If I'm integrating
over the n components
of some particular spin,
I have to make sure
that I remember that this sum
of all of these components is 1.
So I have to integrate
subject to that constraint.
And the way that I have
broken things down now,
I'm integrating over the n minus
1 component of this vector pi.
And this additional
direction, d Sigma,
but I can't do both
of them independently.
Because there's a
delta function that
enforces that sigma squared
plus pi squared equals to 1.
The pi squared corresponds
to the magnitude
of this n minus 1
component vector.
And essentially, I can solve
for this delta function,
and really replace
this sigma over here
with square root of
1 minus pi squared.
But I have to be a little bit
careful in my integrations.
Because this delta
function I can
write as a delta
function of sigma
plus or minus square root
of 1 minus pi squared.
And there is a rule that if
I use this delta function
to set sigma to be equal to
square root of 1 minus pi
squared, like I
have done over here,
I have to be careful that the
delta function of a times x
is actually a delta function
of x divided by modulus of a.
So essentially, I have to
substitute something here.
So this is, in fact, equal
to the integration in the pi
directions because of the
use of this delta function
to set the value
of sigma, I have
to divide by the square
root of 1 minus pi squared.
Which actually
shortly we will write
this in the following way.
I guess there's an
overall factor of 1/2
but it doesn't really matter.
So yes?
AUDIENCE: So what do
you do with the fact
that there are two places where
the delta function is done?
PROFESSOR: I'm
continuously connecting
to the solution that
starts at 0 temperature
with a particular state.
So I have removed that
ambiguity by the starting
points of my cube.
But if I was integrating
over all possibilities,
then I should really
add that on too.
And really just make
the partition function
with the sum of two
equivalent terms--
one around this ground state,
one around another state.
AUDIENCE: The product is
supposed to be for a lattice
site-- for the integration
variable, not for the--
PROFESSOR: Right.
So I did something bad here.
So here I should have written--
so this is an n component
integration that I have
to do on each side.
Now let's pick one of the sides.
So let's say we
pick the side pi.
For that, I have a small
n integration to do.
What does it say?
It basically says
that if, for example,
I am looking at the
case of n equals to 2,
then I have started
with a state that
points along this direction.
But now I'm allowing
fluctuations pi
in this direction.
And I can't simply say that the
amount of these fluctuations,
pi, is going let's say from
minus infinity to infinity.
Because how much
pi I have changes
actually whether it is
small or whether it is large
when I'm down here.
And so there's constraints
let's say on how big pi can be.
Pi cannot be larger than 1.
And essentially, a
particular magnitude
of pi-- how much weight does
it has, it is captured by this.
So that's one thing
to remember when
we are dealing with
integration over unit spins,
and we want to look
at the fluctuations.
The other choice of notation
that I would like to do
is the following.
I said that my
starting [INAUDIBLE]
is a 0 sum over all nearest
neighbors Si dot Sj.
Now in the state
where all of the spins
are pointing in one direction,
this factor is unity.
So the 0 temperature state gets
a factor of 1 here on each one.
Let's say we are in a
hyper cubic lattice.
There are d bonds per site.
So at 0 temperature, I
would have NdK0, basically--
the value of this ground state.
And then if I have
fluctuations from that state,
I can capture that as
follows, as minus K0 over 2.
It's a reduction in this energy,
as sum over ij Si minus Sj
squared.
And you can check that.
If I square these
terms, I'm going
to get 1, 1, 1/2, which
basically reproduces
this, which actually
goes over her.
And the dot product, minus 2 Si
dot Sj, cancels this minus 1/2,
basically gives
you this exactly.
So the reason I write
it in this fashion
is because very shortly, I want
to switch from going and doing
things on a lattice to
going to a continuum.
And you can see that
this form, summing over
the difference between
near neighbors,
I very nicely can go
to a gradient squared.
So essentially that's
what I want to do.
Whenever I have a
sum over a site,
I want to replace it with
an integral over a space.
And I guess to keep
things dimensionless,
I have to divide by a to get d.
So I can call that the density
that I have to include,
which is also the same thing
as the number of lattice
points in the body of the box.
So my minus beta
H in the continuum
goes over to whatever
the contribution
of the completely
aligned state is.
And then whatever the
difference of the spins
is, because of the
small fluctuations,
I will capture through an
integration of gradient of S
squared.
And I call the original
coupling that we're basically
the strength of the
interaction divide by KdK0.
Clearly in order
to get the coupling
that I have in the
continuum, I have
to have this fact of a to the d.
But then in the gradient, I
also have to divide by distance.
So there's something here, a
factor of a to the 2 minus d
that relates these two factors.
It should be the
other way around.
It doesn't matter.
AUDIENCE: Question.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: This step is
only valid for a cubicle--
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So if it was something
like a triangular lattice,
or something, there would be
some miracle factors here.
AUDIENCE: But I
mean like writing
the difference of
the spin squared
as the gradient squared.
Like if it were a
triangular lattice?
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
so the statement
is that whatever
lattice you have,
what am I doing at the
level of the lattice,
I'm trying to keep
things that are
close to each other aligned.
So when I go to the continuum,
how is this captured,
it's a term like a
gradient squared.
Now on the hyper cubic
lattices, the relationship
between what you
put on the bonds
of the hyper cubic lattice and
what we've got in the continuum
is immediately apparent.
If you try to do it on
the triangular lattice,
you still can.
And you'll find that
at the end of the day,
you will get the factor
of square root of 3,
or something like that.
So there's some miracle
factor that comes into play.
And then at the end
of the day, I also
want to replace these
gradient of a squared
naturally in terms of
essentially S has n components.
N minus one of them are pi,
and one of them is sigma.
So this would be minus
K/2 integral d dx.
I have gradient of
the pi component,
and a gradient of the
sigma component squared.
So after integrating sigma
using the delta functions,
I'm going to the
continuum limit.
The partition function
that we have to evaluate up
to various non-singular
factors, such as this constant
over here, is obtained
by integrating over
all configurations
of our pi field,
now regarded as a
continuously varying object
under the dimensional lattice.
And the weight,
which is as follows,
there is a gradient of
pi squared, essentially
this term over here.
There is the gradient
the other term.
The other term, however,
if I use the delta function
in square root of 1
minus pi squared squared.
And then there's this
factor from the integration
that I have to be careful
of, which I can also
take to the exponent, and write
as, again, this density times
log of 1 minus pi squared.
There's, I think, a
factor of [INAUDIBLE].
So the weight that I
had started with, with S
dot S was kind of
very simple-looking.
But because of the
constraints, was
hiding a number of conditions.
And if we explicitly
look at those conditions
and ask what is the
weight of the fluctuations
that I have to put
around the ground
state, these
Goldstone modes, that
is captured with
this Hamiltonian.
Part of it is this
old contribution
from Goldstone
modes, the transfer
modes that we had seen.
But now being more careful, we
see that these Goldstone modes,
I have to be careful about
integrating over them
because of the additional terms
that capture, essentially,
the original full symmetry,
full rotational symmetry,
that was present in
integration over S. Yes?
AUDIENCE: The integration--
the functional integration,
pi should be linked
up to a sphere of 1.
PROFESSOR: This will keep.
So I put that
constraint over here.
And it's not just that it
is limited to something,
but for a particular
value of pi,
it gets this additional weight.
So if you like, once I
try to take my integrals
outside that region, that
factor says the weight as usual.
So this entity is called
the non-linear sigma model.
And I never understood why they
don't call it a non-linear pi
model.
Because we integrate
immediately with sigma.
That's how it is.
So what you're going to do
if we had, essentially, stuff
that the first term not included
any of the other things,
we will have had the
analysis of Goldstone modes
that we had done previously.
The effect of these
things, you can
see if I start making
expansion in powers of pi,
is to generate
interactions that will
be non-linear terms
among the parts.
So these Goldstone modes
that we were previously
dealing with as independent
modes of the system,
are actually
non-linearly coupled.
And we want to know
what the effect of that
is on the behavior
of the entire system.
So whenever we're faced
with a non-linear theory,
we have to do some kind of
a preservative analysis.
And the first thing that
you may be tempted to do
is to expand the
powers of pi, and then
look at the Gaussian part,
and then the higher order
parts, etc.
That's a way of doing it.
But there's actually another
way that is more consistent,
which is to organize
the terms in this weight
according to powers
of temperature.
Because after all, I started
with a zero temperature
configuration.
And I'm hoping
that I'm expanding
for small fluctuation.
So my idea is to-- I
know the ground state.
I want to see what happens
if I go slightly beyond that.
And the reason for
fluctuations is temperature,
so organize terms in this
effective Hamiltonian
for the pis in powers
of temperature.
And temperature, by this I mean
the inverse of this coupling
constant, K,
because even, again,
if I go through
my old derivation,
you can see that
I go minus beta H,
so K0 should be inversely
proportional to temperature.
K is proportion to K0.
It should be inversely
proportional to temperature.
So to some overall
coefficient, let's just
define temperature [INAUDIBLE].
Now we see that at the
level that we were looking
at things before,
from this term it's
kind of like a
Gaussian form, where
I have something like K, which
is the inverse temperature
pi squared.
So just on dimensional grounds,
up to functional forms, etc.
we expect pi squared to be
proportional to temperature
at the 0 order, if you like.
Because, again, if
temperature goes to 0,
there's not going
to no fluctuations.
As I go away from 0 temperature,
the average fluctuations
will be 0.
Average squared will be
proportional to temperature.
It all makes sense.
So then if I look
at this term, I
see that dimensionally,
it is inverse temperature
pi squared is of the
order of temperature.
So this is dimensionally
t to the 0.
Whereas if I start
to expand this,
this log I can start to
expand as minus pi squared
plus pi to the 4th over 2 pi to
the 6th over 3, and so forth.
You can see that subsequent
terms in this series
are higher and higher
order in this temperature.
This will be the order of
temperature-- temperature
squared, temperature cubed.
And already we can see
that this term is small
compared to this term.
So although this
is a Gaussian term,
and I would've
maybe been tempted
to put it in the 0
order Hamiltonian,
If I'm organizing
things according
to orders of temperature, my
0-th order will remain this.
This will be the
contribution to first order,
2nd order, 3rd order.
And similarly, I can
start expanding this.
Square root is 1 minus
pi squared over 2.
So then I take the gradient
of minus pi squared over 2.
I will get pi gradient of pi.
You can see that the lowest
order term in this expansion
will be pi gradient of
pi squared, and then
higher order terms.
And this is something that
is order of pi to the 4th,
so it gives the order of
temperature squared multiplied
by inverse temperatures.
So this is a term that is
contributing to order of T
to 0, T to the 1.
So basically, at order of T
to 0, I have as my beta H0
just the integral d dx K/2
gradient of pi squared.
While at order of
T the 1st power,
I will have a correction
which has two types of terms.
One term is this K/2 integral
d dx pi gradient of pi squared,
coming from what was the
gradient of sigma squared.
And then from here, I
will get a minus rho
over 2 integral d dx pi squared.
And then there will be other
terms like order of T squared,
U2, and so forth.
So I just re-organized terms
in this interacting Hamiltonian
in what I expected to be
powers of this temperature.
Now here we-- one of the
first things that we will do
is to look at this and
realize that we can decompose
into modes by going
to previous space,
I do a Fourier transform.
This thing becomes K/2 integral
dd q divided by 2 pi to the d q
squared pi theta of q squared.
So let's write it as
pi theta [INAUDIBLE].
And again, as usual,
we will end up
needing to calculate averages
with this Gaussian rate.
And what we have here is that
pi alpha of q1 pi beta of q2,
we get this 0-th ordered rate.
The components have
to be the same.
The sum of the two
momenta has to be 0.
And if so, I just
get K q squared.
Now I can similarly
Fourier transform the terms
that I have over here.
So the interactions
to one-- first one
becomes rather complicated.
We saw that when we
have something that's is
four powers of a field.
And when we go to
Fourier space, rather
than having one
integral over x, we
ended up with
multiple integrals.
So I will have, essentially,
Fourier transform
of four factors of pi.
For each one of them I
will have an integration.
So I will have dd
q1, dd q2, dd q3.
And the reason I
don't have the 4th one
is because of the integration
over x, forcing the four q's
to be added up to 0.
So I will have pi alpha
of q1, pi alpha of q2,
Now note that this
high gradient of pi
came from a gradient
of pi squared,
which means that the two
pis that go with this,
carry the same index.
Whereas for the next
factor, pi gradient of pi,
they came from different ones.
So I have pi q3 I beta
minus q1 minus q2 minus q3.
Now if I just written
this, this would've
been the Fourier transform of
my usual 4th order interaction.
But that's not what
I have because I
have two additional gradients.
And so for two of
these factors actually
I had to take the
gradient first.
And every time I take a
gradient in Fourier space,
I will bring a factor of I q.
So I will have here I q1
dotted with Iq let's say 3.
So the Fourier transform of
the leading quartic interaction
that I have, is actually the
form that I have over here.
There is a trivial
term that comes
from Fourier transforming.
It's pi squared because
then I Fourier transform
that, I get simply pi
alpha of q squared.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Does it
matter which q's
you're pulling out
as the gradient?
PROFESSOR: You can see that
these four pis over here
in Fourier space appear
completely interchangeably.
So it really doesn't matter, no.
Because by permutation and
re-ordering these integration,
you can move it
into something else.
No, there is-- I shouldn't--
I'll draw a diagram that
corresponds to that that will
make one constraint apparent.
So when I was drawing
interaction terms for m
to the 4th tier for
Landau-Ginzburg,
and I have something
that has 4 interactions,
I would draw something
that has 2 lines.
But the 2 lines had 2 branches.
And the branching was supposed
to indicate that 2 of them
were carrier 1
index, and 2 of them
were carrying the same index.
Now I have to make
sure that I indicate
that the branches
of these things
additionally have
these gradients
for the Iq's
associated with them.
And I make a
convention the branch,
or the q, that has the gradient
on it, I will put a line.
Now you can see
that if I go back
and look at the origin of
this, that one of the gradients
acts on one pair of
pis, and the other acts
of the other pairs of pis.
So the other dashed line I
cannot put on the same branch,
but I have to put over here.
So the one constraint that
I have to be careful of
is that these Iq' should
pick one from alpha and one
from beta.
This is the diagrammatic
presentation.
So what I can do is to now
start doing perturbation
in these interaction.
You want to do the
lowest order to see
what the first correction
because of fluctuations
and interaction of
these Goldstone modes.
But rather than do
things in two steps,
first doing perturbation,
encountering difficulty,
and then converting things
to a normalization group,
which we've already seen that
happen, that story, in dealing
with the Landau-Ginzburg
model, Let's immediately
do the perturbative
renormalization group
of this model.
So what I'm supposed
to do things
is to note that all
of these theories
came from some
underlying lattice model.
I was carefully drawing
for you the first lattice
model originally.
Which means that there
is some cut off here,
some lattice cut off.
Which means that when
I go to Fourier space,
there is always some kind of a
range of wave numbers or wave
vectors that I have
to integrate with.
So essentially, my
pi's are limited
after I do a little
bit of averaging,
if you like that there is
some shortest wavelength,
and the corresponding
largest wave number, lambda,
in [INAUDIBLE].
And the procedure for
RG, the first one,
was to think about
all of these pi modes,
and brake them into two pieces.
One's that we're responding
to the short wavelength
fluctuations that we
want to get rid of,
and the ones that correspond
to long wavelength fluctuations
that we would like to keep.
So my task is as follows, that
I have to really calculate
the partition function over
here, which in it's Fourier
representation indicates
averaging over all modes
that's are in this orange.
But those modes I'm
going to represent
as D pi lesser, as
well as D pi greater.
Each one of these
pi's is, of course,
an n minus on component vector.
And I have a rate
that i obtained
by substituting pi lesser and
pi greater in the expressions
that I have up there.
And we can see already that
the 0-th order terms, as usual,
nicely separates out
into a contribution
that we have for pi lesser,
a contribution that we have
for pi greater, and that the
interaction terms will then
involve both of these modes.
And in principle, I
could proceed and include
higher and higher orders.
Now I want to get rid of all
of the modes that are here.
So that I have an effective
theory governing the modes
that are the longer wavelengths,
once I have gotten rid
of the short wavelength
fluctuations.
So formally, once I have
integrated over pi greater
in this double
integral, I will be
left with the integration
over the pi lesser field.
And the exponential gets
modified as follows.
First of all, if I were
to ignore the interactions
at the lowest order,
the effect of doing
the integration of the Gaussian
modes that are out here,
will, as usual,
be a contribution
to the free energy of the
system coming from the modes
that I integrated out.
And clearly it also
depends, I forgot to say,
that the range of integration
is now between lambda over b
lambda, where b is my
renormalization factor.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Because you're
coming from a lattice, does
the particular shape of
the Brillouin zone matter
more now, or still not really?
PROFESSOR: It is in no
way different from what
we were doing before in
the Landau-Ginzburg model.
In the Landau-Ginzburg model,
I could have also started
by putting spins,
or whatever degrees
of freedom on a lattice.
And let's say if I was
in hyper cubic lattice,
I would've had Brillouin
zones, such as this.
And the first thing
that we always said
was that integrating
all of these things
gives you an additional
totally harmless component
to the energy that has
no similar part in it.
So we're always searching
for the singularities that
arise at the core
of this integration.
Whatever you do
with the boundaries,
no matter how complicated shapes
they have, they don't matter.
So going back to here.
If we had ignored
the interactions,
integrating over
pi greater would've
giving me this contribution
to the free energy.
And, of course, beta H0 of
pi lesser would've remained.
But now the effect of having
the interactions, as usual,
it is like integrating
into the minus
u with the rate over here.
So I would have an
average such as this.
And we do the cumulant
expansion, as usual.
And the first term I
would get is the average
of this quantity with
respect to the Gaussian rate,
integrating out the high
component modes, high frequency
modes, and high
order corrections.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So right here you're
doing two expansions kind
of simultaneously.
One is you have non-linear
model that you're
expanding different
powers and temperature.
And then you
further on expand it
to cumulants to be able
to account for that.
PROFESSOR: No, because I
can organize this expansion
in cumulants in
powers of temperature.
So this u has an expansion
that is u1, u2, etc.
organized in powers
of temperature.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: And then when
I take the first cumulant,
you can see that the average,
the lowest order term,
will be--
AUDIENCE: The first cumulant
is linear in temperature,
and that's what you want?
PROFESSOR: Right.
So I'm being consistent
also with the perturbation
that I had originally stated.
Actually, since I drew a
diagram for the first term,
I should state that this term,
since we are now also thinking
of it as a correction
in u1, I have
to regard it as 2 factors of pi.
So I could potentially represent
it by a diagram such as this.
So diagrammatically, my u1
that I have to take the average
is composed of
these two entities.
So what I need to do is to take
the average of that expression.
So I can either do
that average over here.
Take the average
of this expression,
or do it diagrammatically.
Let us go by the
diagrammatic route.
So essentially,
what I'm doing is
that every line that I see over
there that corresponds to pi,
I am really decomposing
into two parts.
One of them I will draw as a
straight line that corresponds
to the pi lesser
that I am keeping.
Or I replace it
with a wavy line,
which is the pi greater that
I would be averaging over.
So the first diagram I
had essentially something
like this-- actually,
the second diagram.
The one that comes
from rho pi squared.
It's actually trivial, so let's
go through the possibilities.
I can either have both of
these to be pi lessers-- sorry,
pi greaters.
So this is pi
greater, pi greater.
And when I have
to do an average,
then I can use
the formula that I
have in red about the
average of 2 pi greaters.
And that would
essentially amount
to closing this thing down.
And numerically, it would gives
me a factor of minus rho over 2
integral d dK over 2 pi to the
d in the interval between lambda
over b, lambda .
And I have the
average of pi alpha pi
alpha using a factor
of delta alpha alpha.
Summing over alpha will give
me a factor of n minus 1.
And the average would be
something like K k squared.
So I would have to evaluate
something like this.
But at the end of the day,
I don't care about it.
Why don't I care about it?
Because clearly the result of
doing this is another constant.
It doesn't depend on pi lesser.
So this is an addition
to the free energy
once I integrate modes between
lambda over b to lambda,
there is a contribution
to the free energy that
comes from this term.
It doesn't change
the rate that I
have to assign to configurations
of the pi lesser field.
That's another possibility.
Another possibility is I
have one of them being a pi
greater, one of them
being a pi lesser.
Clearly, when I try to get
an average of this form,
I have an average
of one factor of pi
with a Gaussian
field that is even.
So this is 0.
We don't have to worry about it.
And finally, I will get a
term, which is like this.
Which doesn't involve
any integrations,
and really amounts to
taking that term that I
have over there, and just
making both of those pi
to be pi lessers.
So it's essentially the same
form that will reappear,
now the integration being
from 0 to lambda over 2.
So we know exactly what happens
with the term on the right.
Nothing useful, or important
information emerges from it.
If I go and look at
this one however,
depending on where
I choose to put
the solid lines
or the wavy lines,
I will have a number
of possibilities.
One thing that is
clearly going to be there
is essentially I put pi lesser
for each one of the branches.
Essentially, when i write
it here like this one,
it is reproducing
the integration
that I have over there,
except that, again, it
only goes between 0 and lambda.
And now I can start
adding wavy lines.
Any diagram that has one wavy,
and I can put the wavy line
either on that type
of branch, or I
can put it on this
type of branch.
It has only one factor of pi.
By symmetry, it will
go to 0, like this.
There will be things
that will have
three factors of pi lesser.
And all of these--
again because I'm
dealing with an odd
number of factors of pi
greater that I'm
averaging will give me 0.
There's one other thing
that is kind of interesting.
I can have all four
of these lines wavy.
And if I calculate
that average, there's
a number of ways of
contracting these four
pi's that will give
me nontrivial factors.
But these are also contributions
to the free energy.
They don't depend on the
pi's that I'm leaving out.
So they don't have to worry
about any of these diagrams
so far.
Now I dealt with the 0,
1, 3, and 4 wavy lines.
So I'm left with 2 wavy
lines and 2 straight lines.
So let's go through those.
I could have one
branch be wavy lines
and one branch be
straight lines.
And then I take the
average of this object.
I have a pi greater--
a pi greater here,
and therefore I can
do an average of two
of those pi greaters.
That average will give me a
factor of 1 over K k squared.
I have to integrate over that.
But one of these branches had
this additional dash thing
that corresponds to
having a factor of k.
So the integral
that I have to do
involves something like this.
And then I integrate over the
entirety of the k integration.
This is an odd power, and so
that will give me a 0 also.
So this is also 0.
And there's another
one that's is
like this where I go like this.
And although I do the
same thing now with two
different branches, the k
integration is the same.
And that vanishes too.
So you say, is there
anything that is left?
The answer is yes.
So the things that are
left are the following.
I can do something like this.
Or I can do something like this.
So these are the two things that
survive and will be nontrivial.
You can see that
this one will be
proportional to
pi lesser squared,
while this one is going to
be proportional to gradient
of pi lesser squared.
So this one will renormalize,
if you like, this coefficient.
Whereas this one, we've modified
and renormalize our coupling
straight.
So it turns out
that that is really
the more important point.
But let's calculate
the other one too.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Why do we connect the
ones down here with the loops,
but left all the ends
free in the ones.
Was that just a matter of the
case of how to write diagram,
or does that signify something?
PROFESSOR: Could
you repeat that?
I'm not sure I understand.
AUDIENCE: So when we had two
wavy line, both coming out
one of the diagram, this
line, they just stop.
We connected them
together when we
were writing the ones
on the bottom line.
PROFESSOR: So basically, I
start with an entity that
has two solid lines
and two wavy lines.
And what I'm supposed to do
is to do an integration--
an average of this
over these pi greaters.
Now the process of
averaging essentially joins
the two branches.
If I had the momentum here,
q1, and a momentum here,
q2, if I had an
index here, alpha,
and an index here, beta,
that process of averaging
is equivalent to saying the
same momentum has to go through,
the same index
has to go through.
There is no averaging that is
being done on the solid lines,
so there is-- meaningless
to do anything.
So this entity
means the following.
I have K/ 2 let's call
it legs 1, 2, 3, and 4.
Integral q1 and q2, but q1
and q2 you can see explicitly
are solid.
So these are the integration
from 0 to lambda over b.
I have an integration over
q3, which is over a wavy line.
So it's between lambda
over b and lambda.
If I call this branch alpha
and this branch beta, from here
I have actually pi lesser alpha
of q1 pi lesser beta of q2.
I should have put them
outside the integration,
but it doesn't matter.
And then here I had pi
alpha of q3, pi beta of q4.
But these also had these
lines associated with them.
So I have here actually
an i q3, an i q4.
Again, q4 has to stand for minus
q1 minus q2 minus q3 from this.
And then I had the pi
pi here, which give me,
because of the averaging,
delta alpha beta.
And then I will
have an integration
that forces q2 plus q4 to be 0.
And then I have K q3 squared.
Now q3 plus q4 is the same thing
as minus q1 minus q3, if you
like, because of
that constraint.
So I can take that
outside the integration.
There's no problem.
I have one integration left,
which is 1 over K q3 squared,
but these two then
become the same.
These pi's I will take outside.
I note that because of this
constraint, q1 and q2 being
the same, these two really
become one integration that
goes between 0
and lambda over b.
And these indices have
been made to be the same.
So I have pi alpha of
q, this q, squared.
Then I have the integration
from lambda over b to lambda.
D d q3 2 pi to the d.
Here I have i q3 i q4.
But q4 was said to be minus q3.
So the two i's and the
minus cancel each other.
And I will get a
factor of q3 squared.
And then here I have a
factor of K q3 squared.
So the overall thing
is just that we
can see that the K's cancel.
I have one factor integral
dd q 2 pi to the d.
I have pi alpha of q squared.
And these are q lessers.
I integrated out this quantity.
The q3's vanish, so I really
have the integral of q3
over 2 pi to the d.
Now if I had done the
integral of q3 2 pi
to the d, all the way from 0 to
lambda, what would I have done?
If I multiply this
volume here, that
would be the number of modes.
So this is, in fact, N/V,
which is the quantity
that I have called the density.
But what I'm doing
is, in fact, doing
just a fraction of this integral
from 0 to lambda over b.
So if I do the fraction
from 0 to lambda over b,
then I will get 1
minus b to the minus d.
Sorry, from lambda
over b to lambda.
Then if I had done all of
the way from 0 to lambda,
I will have had one,
but I'm subtracting
this fraction of it.
So the answer is rho 1
minus b to the minus d.
The overall thing here gets
multiplied by rho 1 minus
b to the minus d.
It just would correct that
factor of density that we have.
We'll see shortly it's not
something to worry about.
The next one is really the
more interesting thing.
So here we have this diagram,
which is K/2 integral from 0
to lambda over b.
Essentially, I will
get the same structure.
This time let me write
the pi alpha lesser
of q1 pi beta lesser of q2
outside the last configuration.
I have the integral from lambda
over b to lambda dd of q3 2
pi to the 3d.
And I will have the same
delta function structure,
except that now these factors
of i q become i q1 times i q2.
So I can put them
outside already.
And then I have here
the delta function.
So the only difference is
that previously the q squared
was inside the integration.
Now the q squared is
outside the integration.
So the final answer will
be K/2 integral 0 to lambda
over d d d q 2 pi to the d.
I have a q squared.
pi of q lesser squared.
And the coefficient
of that would
look like what I had before,
except without this factor.
So it's the integral
from lambda over b
to lambda dd of q3 divided by 2
pi to the d 1 over Kq3 squared.
So once I do explicitly
this calculation,
the answer is going to be
a weight that only depends
on this pi lesser
that I'm keeping
and I would indicate that
by beta H tilde, as usual.
That depends of this pi lesser.
And we now have all
of the terms that
contribute to this beta H tilde.
So let's write them down.
There's a number of
terms that correspond
to changes in the free energy.
So we have a V delta f p at
the 0-th order contribution
of delta f p at the first
order that are essentially
a bunch of diagrams, both from
here as well as from here.
But we don't really
care about them.
Then we have types of
terms that look like this.
I can write them already
after Fourier transformation
in real space.
So let me do that.
I have integral dd
x in real space,
realizing that my cut
off has been changed
to ba-- things that are
proportional to gradient
of pi lesser squared.
Now gradient of
pi lesser squared
is the things I in
Fourier space becomes
q squared pi lesser squared.
And what is the coefficient?
I had K/2, which
comes from here.
If I don't do anything, I
just have the 0-th order modes
acting on these.
But I just calculated
a correction
to that that is
something like this.
So in addition to
what I had before,
I have this correction,
K/2 times this integral.
And I'm going to call the
result of this integral
to be I sub d-- see
that this integral is
proportional to 1/K.
And when the integration--
let's call the result
of the integral
Id of b because it
depends on both
dimension of integration,
as well as the factor
V through here.
So I have 1/K Id of b.
So that's one type of
that I have generated.
I started from this
0-th order form.
And I saw that once I make the
expansion of this to the lowest
order, I will get a
correction to that.
And actually, just to
sort of think about it
in terms of formulae,
you see what
happened was that the first
term that I had over here
was pi gradient of
pi repeated twice.
And what I did was
I essentially did
an average of these two pi's and
got the correction to gradient
of pi squared, which is what was
computed here and [INAUDIBLE].
The next term that I have
is this term by itself,
not calculated with the pi
lessers only-- so this object.
So I will write it as K/2
I gradient of pi squared.
There's no correction.
The final term that
I have is this term.
So I have minus rho over
2 pi lesser squared.
And then the correction that I
have was exactly the same form.
It was 1 minus 1 minus
b to the minus b.
The rho over 2 is going to
be hung onto both of them.
You can see that there's
a rho and there's a 2.
And so basically I have
two add this to that.
And to first order, this is
the entire thing of the thing
that I will get.
So this however is
just a course gradient.
It's the first step of the RG.
And it has to be followed by
the next two steps of the RG.
Where here, you
look at you field
and you can see that the
field is much coarser
because the short distance
cut off rather than being a,
has been switched to ba.
So you define your x prime
to x/b, so that you shrink.
You get the same course pixel
size that you had before.
And you also have to
do a change in pi.
So you replace pi lesser
with some factor zeta pi
prime, so that the
contrast will look fine.
So once I do that, you
can see that this effect
of this transformation
is that this coupling
K will change to K prime.
Because of the change
of x with b x prime,
from the integration,
I will get b to the d.
From the two derivatives, I
will get V to the minus 2.
From the fact that I have
replace two pi lessers with pi
primes, I will get a
factor of zeta squared.
And then I will have this
factor K 1 plus 1/K Id of b.
So this is the recursion formula
that we will be dealing with.
Now there is some
subtleties that
go with this formula that
are worth thinking about.
Our original system had really
one coupling parameter K
that because of the constraints
of the full symmetry
of this field, S, part of it
became the quadratic part that
was the free field theory.
But part of it made
the interactions.
But because of this
vertical symmetry,
to form of that
interaction was fixed
and had to be
proportional to K. Now
if we do our normalization group
correctly, to full symmetry
that we had has to be
maintained at all levels.
Which means that the functional
form that I should end up with
should have the same property
in that the higher order
coefficient should be
related to the lower order
coefficient, exactly the same
way as we had over there.
And at least at this stage, it
looks like that did not happen.
That is, we got the
correction to this term,
but we didn't get the
correction to this term.
We shouldn't be worried
about that right
here because we calculated
things consistently corrections
to order of T. And
this was already
a term that was order
of T. So the real check
is if you go and calculate
the next order correction,
you better get a correction
to this term at next order
that matches exactly this.
People have done that,
and have checked that.
And that indeed is the case.
So one is consistent with this.
There are other kinds
of consistency checks
that have happened
all over the place,
like the fact that this
came back 1 minus 1
came out to be b to the minus
d, so that the density is
the same as before,
consistent with the fact
that you shrunk the
lattice after RG so
that the pixel size was
the same as before is
a consequence of that.
You may worry that that's
not entirely the case
because when I do
this, I will have also
a factor of zeta squared.
But it turns out that zeta is
1 plus order of temperature,
as we will shortly see.
So I gain consistent--
everything's
consistent at this level
that we've calculated things.
And the only change
is this factor.
Now the one thing that
we haven't calculated
is what this zeta is.
So to calculate zeta,
I note the following
that I start with
a unit vector that
is pointing at 0 temperature
along this direction.
Now because of
fluctuations, this
is going to be kind of
rotating around this.
So there is this vector
that is rotating.
If you average it over some
time, what you will see
is that the average in all
of these direction is 0.
The variance is not 0,
but the average is 0.
But because of
those fluctuations,
the effective length that
you see in this direction
has shrunk.
How much has it shrunk by
is related to this rescaling
factor that I should chose.
And so it's essentially
average of something
like 1 minus pi squared.
But really it is the
pi lesser squares
that I'm averaging over.
Which the lowest order is 1
minus 1/2 the average of pi
lesser squared, which
is 1 minus 1/2 .
Now this is an N minus
1 component vector.
So each one of the components
will give you one contribution.
The contribution that
you get for one of these
is simply the average
of pi squared, which
is 1 over K k squared, which
I have to integrate over K's
that lie between lambda
over b and lambda.
And you can see that this is
1 minus 1/2 N and minus 1.
It is inversely
proportional to K.
And then the integration
that I have to do
is precisely the same
integration as here.
So it is, again, this Id of b.
So let me write the answer,
say a couple of words about it,
and then we will deal
with it next time.
So K prime is going
to be b to the d
minus 2-- a new
interaction parameters.
It is one factor of
1 plus 1/K Id of b.
And then there's one factor
of this square of zeta.
So that gives you N minus
1 over K Id of b times K.
So we'll analyze this
more next time around.
But I thought I would give you
the physical reason for how
this interaction
parameter changes.
Let's say we are
in two dimensions.
So let's forget
about this factor.
In two dimensions, we can see
that there is one factor that
says at finite temperature,
we are going to get weaker.
The interaction is
going to get weaker.
And the reason for
that is precisely what
I was explaining over here.
That is, you have some
kind of a unit vector,
but because of its
fluctuations, you
will see that it
will loop shorter.
And it is less
likely to be ordered.
The more components
it has to fluctuate,
the shorter it will look like.
So there is that term.
So if this was the
only effect, then K
will become weaker and weaker.
And it will have disorder.
But this effect says
that it actually
gets stronger because
of the interactions
that you have among the modes.
And to show you this to you,
we can experiment with it
yourself.
So this is a sheet of paper.
This bend is an example
of a Goldstone mode
because I could have
rotated this sheet
without any cost of energy.
So this bend is a Goldstone mode
that costs very little energy.
Now this paper has the
kinds of constraints
that we have over here.
And because of
those constraints,
if I make a mode
in this direction,
I'm not going to be able to
bend it in the other directions.
So clearly the mode that
you have this direction,
and this direction, are coupled.
That's kind of an example
of something like this.
Now while it is easy to do this
bend because of this coupling,
if thermal fluctuations
have created modes
that are shorter wavelength,
and I have already
created those modes
over here, then you
can experiment yourself.
You'll see that this is harder
to bend compared to this.
You can see this already.
So that's the effect
that you have over here.
So it's the competition
between these two.
And depending on which
one wins, and you
can see that that
depends on whether n
is larger than 2 or less than 2.
So essentially for n
that is larger than 2,
you'll find that this term wins.
And you get disorder
in two dimension.
And is less than 2,
you will get order
like we know the Ising
model can be order.
But there's other
things that can
be captured by this expression,
that we will look at next time.